so here's the way I'm going to unfold
for you how mathematical induction
begins and then therefore how a normal
structure pretty strong so here's what
I'd like you to do I'd like you to make
a little stop hitting any table because
this is the idea what is this look like
consider I'm going to come up with a
result that we all agree upon that we
get we can access through another beans
so once I do it it will be without a
doubt yes this must be true but I'm
going to do it in this fashion so won't
you consider this series this users no
ordinary series what is this a series on
its the series of the first M odd
numbers okay and you've had the F odd
number over there because it's the first
second third etc okay so this is the sum
of the first and odd numbers now you
guys know because this is a particular
kind of series you have tools to deal
with this right but just for the moment
just suppose you did it
how can I work out what is going what
well I am going to try and take a small
number of cases okay so I'm going to say
well what's the first intern it's just
gonna be one that's the first Oh what
about if I take the first two odd
numbers I have one plus three which is
before you say okay let's see patent yet
let's have a go at the next one one plus
three plus five now it's time to get
auspicious and if I do one more the next
term which I haven't written is seven
right so I'm getting this okay so what I
do is I make a change X um I think I can
see a pattern here I would like to apply
a generalization I'm going to conjecture
that the entire Sun right of all n terms
however may be that my i conjecture that
it's
so how do I go about proving this well I
could go ahead and develop all the
theory to do a narrative congressional
and so on and so on but I'm gonna try it
a slightly different way I'm going to
use mathematical induction so here's the
way this works there are three steps to
it and then correspond to one two three
kind of okay firstly I just want to make
sure my conjecture I'm going to test it
out to see if it works for the very
first case okay this seems like a bit of
an unusual like what does this establish
it's obviously true to the first case
but as you see later either I'm going to
demonstrate I hope the first case is a
critical part of this deductive logic
that I'm going to rely on so the first
case is and equals one that's how many
that's the first term is defined here
there's no zeroth term in this case
cause it started negative one that's not
one of them when N equals one the
left-hand side of this right this thing
here is one plus now where do I end well
the answer is the last term is is one
okay so the left-hand side is just one
there right inside what I'm suggesting
is true there right hand side is one a
square but that's the same thing that I
started with that's the left-hand side
right so therefore what I've shows my
conjecture or my statement is another
way of saying it is true for N equals 1
and N equals 1 is significant because
it's the first case possible sometimes
it might be N equals 2 or n equals 0 or
n equals 4 it kind of depends on what
the conjecture is so I've got that now
secondly I'm going to bring some logic
into play here and this bit is a little
weird
I've tested such an awesome space here
I've tested now you make an assumption
I'm going to assume that my statement is
actually true for some particular value
some arbitrary value so I do know I need
a printable here most people choose K ok
so I'm going to assume this
is true for some arbitrary value okay
and it equals kids they have that with
case what would this look like well the
left-hand side would be 1 plus 3 plus 5
all the way up onto or until what
okay yeah 2 K minus 1 that's the cape on
number 2 yep there it is that's what I'm
substituting you so what I'm thinking is
well if this is true what if I can
assume that it's true on the basis of
this he comes warning right what I now
want to prove is that if it's true for
this time I think I can use logic
deductive logic to prove that it's true
for the next statement which is the k
plus 1 state so I'm going to try and
prove now that the statement is true for
N equals k plus 1 ok this is what I'm
going off done ok so I'm a bunch of
right something that I don't know is
true yet so I'm gonna write this RTP
required to proof now what would the
left-hand side look like for k plus 1
it's gonna start the same way
do you agree it's still gonna get 1 plus
3 and so on now remember the case odd
number is 2 K minus 1 how do you go from
one on over to the next you're always
adding 2 aren't you right so this is the
cave odd number then the k plus 1 odd
number will be this plus 2
do you agree with that that's 2 k plus 1
right okay now I'm bout to write that
down but for reasons that will become
clear in a second so my deductive logic
makes sense I'm also going to include
that term because the kate odd number is
also in my series to agree with that and
then here is the k plus 1 odd number you
can apply that logic to get you can
you could have said where does this come
from it just comes from putting K plus 1
into the last time right that guy is soo
okay plus one take away one do you agree
like that's 2 k plus 2 take away 1 which
is 2 k plus 1 are you happy
so I could have thought about it oh it's
just two - or I could just put it back
into a 40 let's start over okay that is
the left-hand side what's the right-hand
side according to my conjecture what
does it look like
okay all right so this is what I already
know be true this is what I'm assuming
right
I don't know where this troll doll I'm
like what if he is and this is what I
want to try and prove so just like every
other proof you ever time I'm gonna
start with fill that - inside it looks
like this so you could just copy paste
this now here's the cool thing to
remember over here we assumed that it's
true for anyone okay all of this stuff
should be case well but I have all of
this stuff in this right I'm trying to
prove do you see that right look here it
is right there that's all of that stuff
in my assumptions so I'm going to do it
from substitution all of this vanishes
down into K squared if my assumption is
true plus my k plus 1 odd number okay
now because I've just done something
here that's like wait where'd that come
from
answer it came from there we say try
assumptions that didn't come from there
man it came from statement I made but
look at this guy
what's this guy
it's a perfect square right it's the
thing I was after
it's the right hand side okay so so if
it's true for one sorry if it's true
that a turn right which ever want to
learn then it will also be true for the
next one if it's true for this one that
means it should be true for the one
after that and true for the one after
that and um and ah no no no not when I
start where do I start
I started and said hey you know what my
conjecture is true for the first allow
value this one here right so now if I
put in if I said well how about cake was
one what does this mean if it's true for
cake was one it'll be true for K equals
two and then if I put two back in here
if it's true for two then it'll be true
for three add on and on and on
so what am i establishes therefore the
statement is true for N equals k plus
one if and only if it's true for N
equals K because I kind of assumed that
as I so just look right now
unfortunately or maybe fortunately I
don't have an infinite I don't have an
infinite series of dominoes but what
I've just established is I picked out I
picked out any Domino right and I said
well how about that one okay if I can
make that one fall then according to
this deductive logic the next one should
fall to and the next one after that and
the next one after that
but then I've gone ahead and said right
at the beginning guess what
I can push over the first domino that N
equals 1 or n equal 0 or whatever
happens to be the first value right so
hopefully my deductive logic was good
enough
I'm ready to finish off for when I was
at school when I was at school at this
point you had to write my tiny little
essay it explained everything I just
said to you about the dominoes at the K
and K plus 1 etcetera etcetera etcetera
but um I don't go I'm not studying at
school anymore even though still in
school so what you're expected to ie to
tie this all up in the meat burn is to
save and fold everything that you wanted
to set up to prove in the beginning is
true by the principle of mathematical
induction that's what this thing is it's
different it's different from everything
else you've ever seen right now
thankfully we can confirm this
conjecture I of course it doesn't just
come from nowhere it doesn't just come
from here but what is the sum of an AP
guys what is the sum like in general
okay I'm gonna say you're parallel so
there okay so and you could do your
first Alaskan if you like we could also
work there I in terms in this the first
demand on terms what's the first term
plus what's the common difference so you
say add on to it okay what am I getting
you 2 plus 2 and minus 2 cancel cancel
cancel cancel and Wow so here's what's
really really amazing though it's like
yeah we did all this
nice whatever but I could have done all
of this without mathematical deduction
you could okay
put an AP formula on map or a GP for
Bill all writing on the form you like it
will define all of your formulas until
you can use mathematical induction
because there is a clear path okay if
you have a lot people say this is a bit
weave this is a bit silly right
like if you're noted from the beginning
what do you think the answer is going to
be then what's the point of going to all
of this machinery and algebra to prove
something that you already know well the
answer is I don't already know I have a
conjecture it's completely different to
actually knowing and proving that it's
going to be true right
this is watertight it's quite amazing
really you prove something for infinity
right we can draw diagrams we can
produce stuff an algebra right you can
say okay how do I prove that the angle
sum of a triangle
he's going to be up at your name degrees
how do you prove you draw a parallel boy
and then you say I have alternate names
here and here so by definition
you can do that with geometry this is
true for all triangles any value of ABC
you like but when you are in this field
this is apartment don't off to infinity
like you're not limited by simple
diagram to control you need bigger tools
you need bigger guns and that's exactly
what
this is incredible